الله اكبر
كبيرا عيد اختلطت فيه اصوات التكبيرات
باصوات الرصاص
ورائحه البخور السوداني برائحه البارود
والجثث على الطرقات طيبت مظاهر الفرح
بحلول الفطر المبارك وحضرت تفاصيل حرب
تدور في شوارع الخرطوم ودارفور وغيرها من
مناطق البلاد من سرق البهجه من السودانيين
في هذا العيد غامر كثيرون بحياتهم للتنقل
الى المساجد من اجل اداء الصلاه في وطن
يحتاج الى كثير من الدعاء حتى لا يغرق
اكثر فئه حرب البسه ثوب الحداد منذ السبت
الدامي الوضع الانساني المتدهور في زمن
السلام يتجاوز الان مرحله الكارثه مع كل
هدنه لا تحترم وكل وعد بفتح ممرات انسانيه
ينكثف فقدت منظمه الهجره الدوليه احد
موظفيها نعته في بيان ذكرت فيه بعض تفاصيل
الحادثه وقالت انه كان يتنقل مع اسرته
بالقرب من الابيض عندما قتل بالرصاص في
منطقه اشتباكات قبل الهجره الدوليه كانت
منظمه الارضيه خسرت ثلاثه من موظفيها في
دارفورد وعلقت لاحقا عملها بسبب تدهور
الوضع الامني في بلد ثلث سكانه يعتمدون
على مساعدات المنظمه الامميه حتى المنظمات
التي لم توقف عملها رسميا هي اليوم عاجزه
عن تقديم خدماتها وايصال المساعدات
المطلوبه بالحاح للمحتاجين رسمت اليونيسف
صوره مرعبه عن اوضاع الاطفال خلال وقبل
ايام الصراع الاخير قتلت تسعه اطفال منذ
بدء الاشتباكات اصيب ما لا يقل عن 50 طفلا
اعلنت المنظمه التوقف الرعايه الاساسيه
التي كانت تقدم لنحو خمسين الف طفل يعانون
من سوء التغذيه الحاد قبل المواجهات
الاخيره كان اكثر من 600 الف طفل يعانون
من سوء التغذيه الحاد
يحدث كل هذا في بلد هو ثالث منتج للذهب في
افريقيا جعلته الحروب وحسابات السياسه
والمصالح الداخليه والاقليميه والدوليه من
بين الدول الفقيره عالميا تتواصل نداءات
الاستغاثه من داخل وخارج السودان لتقديم
المساعده للمرافق الطبيه العاجزه عن علاج
المرضى وانقاذ الارواح الوضع الانساني
والطبي سيء للغايه حتى هذه المستشفيات
التي نتحدث عنها هي مستشفيات اساسيه
يمكنها تقديم الخدمه الطبيه للجرحى
والمصابين هذه المستشفيات هي على حافه
الاغلاق في اي لحظه نحن ارسلنا عدد من
النداءات
الى كل الجهات اصدقاء السودان بالخارج
للضغط على الطرفي الصراع لوقف هذا
العباسيه فورا وفتح ممرات امنه اعلنت
نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ارتفاع عدد
المستشفيات المتوقفه عن العمل في الخرطوم
وولايات اخرى الى 55 من اصل 78 مضيفه ان
اربعه مستشفيات في الابيض تعرضت للقس
اول ايام عيد الفطر لم يكن سعيدا ابدا على
السودانيين سواء منهم عالقون وسط معارك
لطائل منها سوى الخراب او من هم في الخارج
يتابعون اخبار اهل ووطن تحت النار وسماء
لم ينقش عنها دخان الانفجارات